question was
always wanted to be a reporter and I
said that which is true that I was lucky
and blessed for whatever reason I always
wanted to be a reporter from the
earliest memories of my life when you
play those games as children do you want
to be a fireman anymore didn't she want
to be able airplane pilot I always said
that I wanted to be a reporter I didn't
know the word journalism until some
years later it was always a reporter in
my time in place of being a reporter
meant to me at that time and for a long
time after that to aspire to be a big
file and reporter for major newspaper
radio in my youth was still young
television invented but was just a dream
and for most people but I think the
reason was when I think back about why
always it would be a reporter my parents
both of whom were now gone were typical
of people many people during the
Depression era that neither one is
finished high school they both work
they're back in their hands but they
were avid newspaper readers so my guess
is that because I saw my parents reading
newspapers discussing newspapers and
what was in the paper that in my small
childish mind
planted to see that what's in the
newspaper is important it was important
to my parents so it's important to me
and from that grew this determination to
be a reporter but I recognized I was
very lucky in this a class because a lot
of people understand we don't I don't
know what they want to do until later in
life but I always aspire to be a
reporter you've talked about
what's a field reported being out field
you've talked about the paramount
importance of field reporting of being
out in the field as being important part
of any kind of any any journalist
training or any background for any
journalism why do you see the experience
of reporting out in the field as so
critical to being a journalist well I do
see it as critical that's what I call
you have to walk the ground
you can't walk the ground on every story
but there's there's no substitute for
eyewitness and eyewitness an ear witness
testimony of a good reporter working the
telephones is very important as well
it's the next best thing to wearing out
shoe leather but let's say covering
combat for example that you can read
everything from home or forward you can
see all the great films of all quiet of
the Western Front but to convey to the
reader the listener to the viewer the
reality of the savagery of war what war
is as opposed to what it appears to be I
think you have to walk around and
investigating reporting absolutely no
substitute for knocking on doors walking
around talking to people sometimes
knocking on doors and saying what's
going on in there what's really going on
in there there's no substitute for it
I have no patience for because it's
thinner than my experience of what I
call hot house report that is people who
depend on their ability to light as you
and I both know Roger that the bedrock
of our have journalism is the ability to
write but sometimes I think far too
often people use their talent for
lighting the ability to light as a
substitute or as I say she led them on
the ground telephone of the year kind of
reporting but there there are other
views those of you who don't know
journalism perhaps some of you do these
are my views there are other journals
reviews about it but I am a go there see
here walk the ground and try to be an
honest broker information with the
auditors you've talked about the
influence of the early radio newscasters
particularly in that when you were kid
the world war two broadcasters severide
and Morrow from from World War two
reporting and how it influenced you what
lessons did you learn from that kind of
reporting from the front from the front
lines well I learned so many lessons but
it is true keep in mind we're talking
about a long time ago
that I grew up primarily in an
environment during the 1930s where print
was virtually everything radio was still
new now what every dollar Merle who is
not just the patron saint of broadcast
journalism he was the founding Saints
journalism radio really came of age
during what Winston Churchill called the
Gathering Storm that is the
those years leading up to World War two
and then reaches maturity during World
War two and as a child it turned out I
was very fortunate I had rheumatic fever
twice in my rough period of puberty I
was bedridden once for nine months
another time for about seven months and
this coincided with the early part of
the American part of World War two so an
answer your question that mind you I was
printing orated because my family
basically read newspapers now comes
radio where they create these vivid
images in your mind I mean get the
picture I'm bedridden the radio is a
constant companion and here are these
voices of Edward or merle charles
collingwood erik severide this is in the
pantheon of broadcast journalism heroes
they hear them report from these faraway
places with strange-sounding names
reporting big events to say that I was
captivated probably underestimated I
still aspire to be a print reporter but
there's no question that this piqued my
interest
and I can remember walking to junior
high school and sort of recreating
battle scenes in my mind and trying to
emulate not very well I'm sorry to say
but emulate the great voices I
Muro severide Collingwood it's a long
list but what I took from that is first
of all Murrow had such high standards
he had among the highest standards in
the history of American journalism not
just broadcast journalism not just radio
and television but as he brought
broadcast news in the creation and the
almost almost single-handedly broadcast
news as we know it he had the highest
ethical standards
the highest standards of collaborating
information he was an excellent writer
he was as a lot of people including you
narrator a better writer for himself
because he wrote for the year then he
wasn't in print what I took from it was
the high ethical standards Merle had the
also the sense of adventure again when
you're a child to think about Eric
severide as you did bailing out over
Burma doesn't get much better than that
if your child because it's radio and you
imagine this I parachuted out of Burma
Wow or every wrong world flying bombing
missions over Berlin at these images
sort of stick in your mind and it just
reinforced my determination to be a
reporter I said I want to do that I
wasn't saying at that time I wanted to
be in radio and television I still
wanted to be in print but I listened I
heard continue to read papers and said
you know not only is that what I want to
be that's
so you grew up in an era really you grew
up in an era that really where radio was
being superseded by television or was
soon to be superseded by television and
now we're in an era where television is
giving way to the Internet so I'm
wondering what you see is some of the
biggest challenges facing journalism
today as we as it moves into this new
era well first of all it is true that
you went from newspapers being dominant
radio comes on the newspaper people said
we're dead if people can hear this over
the radio of inevitable newspapers well
it reached the stage for radio news was
perhaps dominant but not by much
newspapers can thrive when television
came along the same things we said
listen if you can see it and hear it in
your living room who's going to listen
to radio who's going to read a newspaper
my point here is that while it expanded
people's ability to get information it
didn't wipe out the predecessors now
we're in the Internet age and I believe
it to be true that the Internet has if
it hasn't already become the dominant
source of news for most people which I
could argue it already has done that
it's destined to become that and very
quickly but that does not mean the death
of television news radio news or
newspapers newspapers are very dire
straits it's true but now to your
question what we can take to number one
if it's journalism and I can't emphasize
this too much particularly for anyone in
the audience who may be aspiring to
career in journalism writing is the
bedrock of the cramped whether you're in
newspapers radio television or
dream of being on the Internet if you
want to be a journalist the first thing
is to make yourself as good a writer as
you can and dedicate yourself to a
lifetime of right that's number one
number two with the news on the Internet
the internet covers a lot of things
other than use but news on the Internet
there's a struggle I think it'll be a
long struggle to establish what are the
ethical standards for the Internet what
is what is the standard for quote good
journalist quality journalism of
integrity on the Internet we're in the
process of trying to work these things
out such fundamental questions of well
who is and isn't a journalist anybody
can get on the internet anybody can do a
blog anybody can do a tweet and say
listen I'm in news so we're at this
stage I think with the internet now if
it isn't already dominant for news it
will be the ethical standards the
standards of what a good journalism
we're still in the process of being
formed the definition of who is and is
not a journalist who should be
classified as a journalist with the
First Amendment rights so forth it's all
being worked out and I think it would
take a long time to work that out what
is a long time I would say two to five
years the other big issue with news on
the web
is who is going to pay for it the
advertiser model which served newspapers
and then in turn radio and in turn
television on that advertised appetisers
finance such things as international
news the coverage of wars investigative
reporting all of which are very
expensive we haven't yet nobody that I
know of has saw the question well we
want to have that on either net we want
to have it in abundance we want to have
in greater abundance and
hedid but how do you pay for do you a
subscriber base is being tried by a
number of people thus far with very few
exceptions the idea of paying for this
kind of journalism with subscriber fees
is not proved to be sufficient the
advertising model as I say has not
proved to be sufficient I have no doubt
that this will sort itself out but I
think it's important for the public to
understand that American journalism and
journalism worldwide but particularly
American journalism which is the world
leader is now on what untold the Roman
Catholic Church calls an interactive
method which is to say the old order is
gone but the new order is not yet in
place and in this inner eggman is danger
for generation are you optimistic that
when it all gets sorted out we're going
to have a place and access to quality
journalism I am I think I said to you
earlier I'm an optimist by experience
and by nature I worry about it I don't
think it's guaranteed and so much as
perhaps even naive or sophomoric as it
may sound to say this I think a lot
depends on the American public but what
they demand of news if the American
public there certainly is a threat a
thirst for quality news of integrity but
it may take more than just a thirst I
think it will take a demand for it so
while I'm worried about it and answer
your question I am optimistic
you know we're here as part of the Yale
environmental film festival and it seems
to me that in recent years particularly
with your work at HDNet you've been
doing a lot of environmental subjects
climate change melting out sheets in
Greenland illegal logging and Madagascar
carbon offsets very good
on that why is it am i right in thinking
you have been pursuing a lot more
environmental stories and if so why
well the answer is yes we have been
pursuing more stories and particularly
have we been interested in doing
investigative work with an emphasis in
environmental area why I think it's
important you get a lot of argument
about this but I think the two biggest
running stories of the 21st century
certainly two of the most important
running stories or in no particular
order whether we can save the planet and
the rise of China as first an economic
superpower which they already are and
whether they become what I've called an
all-purpose superpower that is a
military superpower an economic
superpower these are these are my two
two stories I think the biggest stories
of at least the early part of the 21st
century if someone wants to argue with
others there's certainly two of them
now given that when I came to HDNet
which is a satellite and cable channel
program owned by Mark Cuban an
entrepreneur out of Dallas who perhaps
his best known for owning the Dallas
Mavericks basketball team I wish you
were best known for sponsoring dan
Rather reports and
in some circles I think he is but when I
came I didn't know him and he came to be
and said that he wanted me to do
a news program for him and he said I
will give you complete total absolute
editorial and creative control this is
at the very least rare in American
journalism rare in journalism anywhere I
think it's unique and so when we agreed
on that I was for the first time in my
career free totally absolutely free to
pursue those subjects that one I thought
was important and to that interested me
so we have tried to make part of our DNA
on HDNet investigating reports strong
international coverage and to a degree
of politics and so within that when we
formed the program we said we're going
to do a lot of things but this is this
is what we want to be our sole but the
basic reason on covering environmental
stories number one they're undercover
while one can argue in I would argue
that coverage has increased some over
recent years the increase in coverage
has not been commensurate with the
growing importance of the subject
secondly particularly investigating what
I call deep digging investigative
reports on environmental subjects it's
expensive it takes time frequently when
you start out on something when you get
to the end of it you say well it wasn't
what we thought it was and so for all of
those reasons particularly when it comes
to investigating stories and involving
the
environment there's a shortage I have no
illusions that we can make a big
difference I don't think we can but
whatever difference we can make in
bringing attention to the audience
stories about the environment and
particularly stories about the
environment that powerful people and
institutions don't want the public to
know we we jump on that like a local
rabbit will you mention one of the the
overriding issues that that you think
need to be addressed the issue of
climate change it's an issue that is
difficult to convey to people because
the effects of it are the most serious
effects of it are not immediate they're
out there in the future
and even recent studies even show that
people polls of showing that people are
actually more skeptical now increasingly
skeptical of what the global warming has
even happening how do you think
journalists can convey this issue and
explain this issue best to people
because it seems to up till now they
haven't done a very good job of it or
they haven't succeeded well probably
both of those things have done a very
good job and haven't succeeded well say
how can we improve it how can public
knowledge be expanded one fact it's very
hard sometimes to get the facts and even
when you get the facts it is true it's
an axiom in journalism that you can know
all the facts and still not know the
truth but get as many facts as you can
and for television and I would say the
same thing about radio and written word
to find examples you mentioned we've
done
the melting ice in Greenland we also did
a separate story on the melting glaciers
one there are some facts that are well
known there are some facts in dispute
but there's no question that by and
large glaciers have been in are
disappearing at an alarming rate now you
can argue about what has caused this but
it is a fact that is happening now if
you can with the power of the television
camera if you can demonstrate with
pictures or even still pictures in the
newspaper and for that matter
intelligent discussions on regularly
where you create word picture these are
the two most powerful ways to convey a
story one know your facts acknowledged
when the facts are in dispute present
arguments on both sides or if they're
six sides presented those arguments as
well and then you have demonstrations as
you know so well Roger because you're so
good at it another accident journalism
is don't tell me about a thousand people
tell me about one person and so it is
the environment don't try to tell me
about the whole world beginning to
disappear go to Mississippi show people
how the shoreline is disappearing as the
Gulf Rises and you say folks you may
want to argue about whether global
warming is happening over a long period
of time but these are the facts in one
place keep in mind that what about sixty
percent of the population in our country
lives on our very near a coastline you
take my point you pick one place where
you can demonstrate yeah I'm not going
to try to tell you about every place in
the United States
never mind every place in the world I'll
give you one example
now here are the known facts here's some
facts that are in dispute here are the
pictures here's where the coastline was
six months ago
here's where it was six years ago here's
where it is now you make your own
decisions you make your own judgments
about what you think about that
but you can't deny that it's happening
use the word skeptical before Roger and
I'm glad you did that I have I
recognized that with much of the public
the word cynicism and cynic is
frequently associated with journalists
and journalism I don't believe in being
cynical it is critical absolutely
crucial for journalists to be skeptical
and I don't lament skepticism on the
part of the public I welcome I think
it's very healthy someone say well Dan
Rather says doesn't such or the New York
Times says less and such which show me
fair enough but I for with this school
and people who are saying to themselves
listen I'm interested in the environment
I'm interested in doing things that
conveys a sense of global warming
climate change why we need to be
concerned about it the following things
are true got to establish the facts have
to acknowledge when facts are in dispute
get as many points of view as you
possibly can
don't try to show or explain too much
keep in mind don't tell me about a
thousand places tell me about one place
it's demonstrating and also this is sort
of inside if you will inside television
journalism if you want to tell a story
on radio or television I think this also
applies in print there are very few
things that can match a strong character
we're going to at some point deal with
the story about the disappearing
Louisiana coast and the problem is over
in a moment but once we decide okay this
is a story this is a good story it's an
important story what's happening on the
coastline of Louisiana and to certain
measure the whole Gulf Coast coastline
this is a good story this is an
important story it's an interesting
story it's an important story so how do
we tell this story well one we will go
there walk the ground get as many
pictures as we can but we're also
looking for strong characters local
people expert with the Army Corps of
Engineers so if you're thinking about
putting together some video for the
internet I don't mean this is a heavy
number but I do find when people try to
tell the story
with with pictures put together
something some video for the internet or
a documentary the most common mistake
and I've made thousands if not sometimes
myself is not finding a strong enough
character and characters to help carry
your narrative so you mentioned the
project you're working on on the
Louisiana coastline and the Mississippi
and you brought we have here today some
clips of it's a work in progress but we
have some clips of what you're working
on that we're going to see shortly can
you explain a little bit about the
issues that this is this reporters is
addressing and and what the problems are
well the issue is I've mentioned before
the issue is the disappearing Louisiana
coastline and why you should care about
it not only why you should care about it
if you live in Texas Oklahoma Arkansas
or someplace along the Gulf Coast but if
you live in Seattle or Omaha why you
should care about it so when this story
was first proposed our question the
leadership that broadcast was well first
of all what is the story why is this
story important since when we came
convinced that it was important how can
we make it interesting and the story
line basically is that the Mississippi
coastline is disappearing part of it has
to do with the rise of the water level
in the Gulf of Mexico part of it has to
do with the handling of sludge from the
Mississippi I ask you to keep in mind
how long and how large the Mississippi
River is how vital it is as a
transportation waterway and ask you to
keep in mind that we're after the great
floods of the early parts of the 20th
century we the people of the United
States through the Corps of Engineers
embarked on a long somewhat slow plan to
stop the flooding caused by the
Mississippi and his tributary
tributaries and we built tremendous dams
and other flood control things
now one result of those had
that the natural flow that help nourish
the wetlands of Louisiana and began to
be greatly interfered with if you'll
pardon that syntax and the Army Corps of
Engineers now takes sludge from the
Mississippi River in order to keep it an
open waterway for transport
they take the sludge and they dump it
into the Gulf of Mexico they take it out
of the Gulf of Mexico they only put
about roughly fifteen percent of the
sludge from the Mississippi do they take
and try to if you will recycle it to
help keep the wetlands save as many of
the wetlands as possible
and also to save such things as barrier
islands and so our story is what is
happening why is this happening in
Louisiana they want to use much more of
the sludge to do what I described to
help save the wetlands rebuild the
barrier islands and keep the coastline
from constantly shrinking they're in a
dispute with the federal government
basically through the Corps of Engineers
of saying we've got to have more of this
sludge out of Mississippi to help save
our coastline and the Corps of Engineers
takes the view we're interested in doing
that we do what we can but our our main
directions from Congress or to keep it
open as a waterway and to prevent
flooding so its case of one bureaucracy
not quite knowing what the other is
doing and being dispute with it so
that's our story now with this story
obviously it's important to Louisiana's
but the story would not be worth our
doing on a national basis unless we
could explain to people this is why this
is important to you keep in mind this is
just one place along the u.s. coast that
this is a growing problem on a global
basis to say nothing for our country
ourselves accentuated and made more
dangerous more perilous by the fact of
global warming and the rising level of
our oceans to see ways
I think you need
I think I'll turn around let's see if it
blocks anybody's view if it doesn't just
get off maybe push your seats
this used to be a home that is my family
in that my husband died in his the
memories I have in here and to know the
after each storm it just got worse and
worse I did when I came is like did this
it took everything we look at this like
the biggest environmental challenge that
that our nation is facing today
countless studies have shown you can you
can you spend proactively on these types
of mitigation measures and it pays off
in spades in the future getting the
federal government to shift that from
that reactive posture to the proactive
posture has been very very challenging I
asked the state government to give me a
if you will a position statement and
basically they said following restoring
wetlands with more dredge material would
actually protect the same shipping
channels the Army Corps is trying to
keep open with the dredging program
channels that could be overrun by a gulf
storm surge unimpeded by eroded wetlands
do you agree with them well I think when
when I talked about the beneficial yeast
program what we did what we've conducted
since the 1970s that we are doing that
and there's no question about it if you
can bill marsh behind the behind the
levees behind the waterways it does
provide a buffer and it does have
impacts on storm surge from hurricanes
and also from riverine flooding and it's
your contingent that's what you're doing
now we are doing it to the maximum
extent practical it's it's something
that's very possible to do the equipment
set up for it there's not a issue the
issue is cost it would cost about to do
this beneficiary's right material here
would cost at least three times as much
dredging funds
and to do these because it takes that
much longer so the issue isn't whether
it can be done it's whether it's
economical or feasible to do it in this
particular location well how much time
do we have before the damage becomes
irreversible or do we have any time well
every day we wait the more difficult it
becomes at the moment we still have a
skeleton of the coast left and we can
put the flesh back on that skeleton if
we wait until that skeleton wastes away
then we'll be building that - and
essentially we will be building a new
Louisiana in open water we have to grab
on to that bit of Louisiana that we have
left and build around it and get that
River and get that Marsh back in there
building up again what's this thing
what's being lost here alright that's a
big question okay everything here when I
come out here I feel something I feel an
energy here because this place is alive
you know if there's a living thing every
square inch around here's something
moving all the time and you know that
kind of life as an artist you know
speaks to you and you know it inspires
you and you know when when I see it die
and it it kills me you know it really it
shuts down that connection that I have
with the land I think we're you know I
think the entire thing here is is
inspired by the land that we live on you
know the entire culture that we live by
you know all the city as long as I can
I'll stay here as long as I can't why is
that important to you the memories this
is my place this is my home this is what
my heart was to be my soul was to be and
I'll free
I'm here I feel like I can look at the
waters to be easy
it's awesome just to look it's super
silent is there a point of no return
there's a point where if we don't do
anything then the coast of the future
looks so different from the coast of the
past that you might not recognize it
they'll always be a coastal Louisiana
the question is what is it going to look
like
yes manners kids me God
well done well done wouldn't you write
that I wrote that uh amount about
five-six mono about eight years ago now
when you were out here yeah I wrote that
and one of the small says dead you know
and was inspired by what I was feeling
you know but this place is dying it
tells you that it's tired you know
after watching that is whether the man
from the Army Corps of Engineers was
that nervous because of it the issues or
because he was being interviewed by Dan
Rather no I think it was the issue and
keep in mind this this man this Colonel
is in charge of the Louisiana district
of the Corps of Engineers he came in
after Katrina he is in my judgment
everything you'd want a military officer
to be he's a combat veteran but he's
he's a spokesman who was chosen to
answer our questions I think he's the
best he could but there's one thing it
this is still a work in progress and
this is only a sampling of what we have
that I do want to mention my guess is
that a lot of people in the audience
were aware of this when you come to
these these kinds of issues in these
kinds of places and in this particular
one you have to keep in mind I have a
lot of sympathy with the colonel with
the Corps of Engineers and certainly
with the people in the coastline of
Louisiana that what's at play here and
we should not duck or dodge it or try to
shift it off to the side is very
powerful corporate financial interests
the oil and petroleum interest the
shipping interests who have tremendous
influence through their campaign
contributions in Washington are very big
players in what the Corps of Engineers
decides to do when they decide to do it
if you can notice the colonel said in
effect my orders are to do it this way
those orders come from Congress where I
just want to note just to remind
ourselves that the shipping interests
and the petroleum interests and other
very powerful international corporate
interests have their lobbyists busy all
the time working behind the scenes to
affect decisions that are made not just
for Louisiana but for everywhere and
again it
maybe stating the obvious but I don't
think it can be stated often enough that
we have to face that fact because it is
a fact you mentioned the importance of
character and finding a character to
tell the story it seemed like there you
had at least two very strong potential
characters well thank you we hope so
that for I would say for a fairly short
video piece on the web you need at least
one strong character and one pretty
strong supporting characters now the
longer the program we hope to make an
hour out of this program one-hour
program out of it
you probably need at least two strong
leading characters and three or four
other characters I don't like to talk in
movie terms but this has to do with the
casting of your piece and again I know
there are people in the audience who are
interested in saying listen I've got an
environmental story I want to put
together some video for it I would just
footnote bottom of the page don't forget
to build around characters because it
helps carry your narrative so well well
we do have a lot of people here in the
audience and on campus who are involved
in environmental issues and sometimes
it's not just telling the good story but
how to even get the message out to the
media to convince the media that these
are stories that need to be told issues
that need to be explored what advice
could you give or would you give to
someone who was involved in
environmental activism or environmental
advocacy of on an issue on on getting
their story out well what a good
question and I don't like to give advice
because most of the time my advice is
not worth the time it takes to give it
but for whatever it may be worth it no
particularly
number one there is no substitute for
perseverance even relentlessness you
have a good story you say yourself I
know this is a good story I'm just
having great deal difficulty getting
anyone to notice it's a good story it's
one of the fundamentals of journalism as
a craft as a profession if you will
you have to be pretty near relentless
all the time and you certainly have to
be persistent
so termination persistence just keep
trying is very important second is to
ask yourself to be honest with yourself
so many of us fall in love with a story
and we become convinced within ourselves
I've done this again thousands of times
you see I spoil this is a really
interesting story this is a really
important story is to give yourself a
gut check as to whether you believe that
but is it true and one way of giving
yourself that gut check that test is how
many people are going to be affected by
this so ask yourself those questions
that the internet if you can get and
I'll use the shorthand for this if you
can get the story to go viral on the
internet you know first get it placed
almost any place on the internet then
try to get people to link to it then
what we might call major media centers
that is those with national and
international distribution if they
notice it's becoming bi or anything
close to bio on the internet they're
most likely looking to pick it up but
other ways are letters well written well
presented this is an important story and
this is why it's an important story this
is an interesting story and this is why
it's an interesting story
I recognize that email is the corner of
the realm these days but still typing
out a letter carries more weight than an
email for one thing your average
decision maker is inundated with emails
from people who say I've got an
interesting story I've got an important
story he gets when it comes to slow mail
it can make a difference it's a novelty
tape Orton said it's a novelty
it's getting to be a novelty but in the
same way that a thank-you note our
condolence note it's handwritten on
not suggestion your story ideas be
handwritten but slow mail it carries
more weight but whatever up to and
including now it's it's got a better
chance at cracking through than an email
word-of-mouth is also extremely
important I say there's no self-serving
way up written some books I don't
understand the book business but I know
when it comes to selling books that word
of mouth is underestimated so that leads
to the question well how do you get
word-of-mouth started say the internet
the Internet is a powerful tool for
getting internet started getting
word-of-mouth started but anything and
everything you can think of word of
mouth but I want to come down to if if
you if you as objectively as possible if
you say this is an important story it is
an interesting story and I have done my
homework I have the goods here then just
suck it up be determined be just keep
coming and a lot of the time you will
crack through well we wanted to make
sure we left some good time for
questions so maybe it's now time to turn
to the audience Chandra we're going to
have a microphone out there for people
are not necessary okay Roger just before
you do that if I may and I'm sorry for
interruption but I would appreciate the
ladies in general if you give my
colleague Chandra Simon who's one the
great environmental reporters of her
time I do not overstate it a round of
applause she's the reason I'm here today
well I agree and it will be part of our
report that's true that the Army Corps
of Engineers listen we're not perfect
over the years we've made our mistakes
we've made some mistakes there are some
legal questions involved but we that is
true we will include it in the piece and
I want to make clear to any and
everybody here that by this small
sampling of what we're doing nor by
anything I say or by a piece do we mean
to make the Corps of Engineers the black
hat if you will the villain the one
thing about journalism that you learned
pretty early is you have to allow for
light and shade sometimes you have black
hats and white hats but most of the time
is sort of something in between and so
it is with this story which is very
complex story of what's happening in
Louisiana and indeed what's happening
around our coasts and it's very easy to
say when you go down and you talk to the
people in southern Louisiana with their
nice accent with their crawfish etouffee
and nice songs to see them as the white
hats and the people of corn engineers
and apply but your point spare will have
taken and we are aware of that and we'll
be in our of me to it
well thank you very much for the
question
and frankly I'd like to come back in at
the time and devote more time to it but
in short this is my story this is my
song and I'm going to sing it loud and
clear we do have freedom of the press in
this country and to the extent that
practically nobody else in the world has
it however I think American journalism
is in crisis I sometimes debate this
with my colleagues I never rule out the
possibility they may write we're in
crisis for a number of reasons not the
least of which is in some ways and I do
not accept myself from this criticism in
some ways we journalists have lost our
lost our guts
we've lost our grip and journalists
including myself and journalism I I
often think needs a spine transplant
some of it is a lack of just listen
stand up as to the damn question and
keep asking the question and take the
heat however there are larger forces at
work here and much larger movement or
history if you will that what's happened
particularly over the last 15 or 20
years is the tremendous corporatization
politicalization and tribulation of the
news those of us in journalism have a
lot to answer for including myself when
it comes to those things but so do
people in government and so do you we
the people because increasingly a very
few very large international
corporations controlled most of the mass
distribution of news in the country that
as recently certainly as the 1950s there
were more than 50 journals broadcast
entities in the country that could be
said to be mass distribution very large
regional or national distribution there
are now at most sick
by my count four but they're no more
than six very large international
corporations control roughly eighty or
more percent of the mass distribution
and ears in the country now mark that
and then mark that what you have
increasingly and this has happened not
just in my lifetime in yours but over
the last I would say 12 to 15 years an
increase there must be a general way to
put this of big very big business being
in bed with very big government in
Washington and by the way in both
parties if you will both Democrat and
Republican and what you have is that
these large international corporate
entities for which for whom news is only
a very small part they need legislation
passed in Washington or legislation
stopped in Washington they have
regulations they want adjusted or done
away with in Washington they have needs
from those in power in Washington and to
a degree that I think most people don't
understand that big government and big
business I'm talking about very big
business to a large extent determine
what news you see I would say whether
you consider yourself a Republican a
Democrat a conservative liberal or
Mugwump this is not what we need and
this is not what we want and I don't
think that we the people have addressed
this problem this goes to the core of
what I think you were talking about have
addressed this problem and sometimes
when you say to yourself gosh why isn't
there more about the environment climate
change even quote small stories about
the environment well one of the reasons
is because of what I just mentioned to
you that these very large interests
don't want in many cases this kind of
thing out for example the Mississippi
story I'm not pointing it to I hope over
pointing to this is a story very large
shipping interests very large petroleum
interests they don't want anybody
delving too far into what's happening
with the Mississippi River what happens
to this ledge and a change in policy
sorry that that took so long I have a
longer version but mercifully I won't
give it to you tonight
you know I do apologize to you madam I
didn't hear all the question did you
hear that Roger and let me move
I think I understand that this is one of
the problems is that many of these
things are very complex and with
television television is great at a lot
of things for example it's terrific at
taking you there it is the proverbial
magic carpet I can take you to South
Louisiana and show you the place
television is dipped at its shortcomings
it has difficulty with depth your
question of how do you deal with the
complexities the answer is on television
not very well we do the best we can
we'll say that increasingly that with
most programs that call themselves quote
news and let's face it there are many
programs that are designed for
entertainment who called themselves news
the the Creed these days is the shorter
the better and with many subjects
particularly subjects the environment
you can't do it in a minute and a half
piece or a three-minute piece or even a
five-minute piece I'm not trying to sell
you something here but our program is an
hour we have the leeway to devote an
hour to a subject or a series of hours
if we want but as I understand your
question we're aware the complexity of
these issues we're also aware of our
shortcomings in television it's one
reason that I tell audiences at large I
don't need to say this at Yale but I
tell artists at large if you want to be
well-informed about environmental issues
such as global warming not only do you
should you be on the internet watch
television listen to radio but you have
to read from time to time and yes you
have to read a book from time to time
you find the MSNBC encouraging these
days with like Rachel Maddow and Keith
Olbermann and I can't even understand
what made them switch but they seem to
be coming around to sanity and there are
a couple of TV stations for free speech
TV and link TV that do go in to let the
documentaries probably your show will
end up on there eventually if if you let
it it's it's a great outlet for these
kind of thought-provoking
environmental shows I just wanted to
mention those well one of the things and
again I apologize I don't think it's my
hearing or the acoustics is just BOTS
and sure I heard everything
but you mentioned MSNBC which is
obviously made a decision in there at
least in their nighttime primetime
programming to appeal to a niche as I
say in the east a niche audience of
people they say look we'll be the
counterpoint to Fox News which is
right-of-center
and we'll be left or centered and
they've done reasonably well in the
cable universe in the over-the-air ways
ABC NBC CBS world their audiences are
comparatively small but in the cable
world their audiences large and
increasingly this is a problem
particularly for electronic journalism
setting aside the Internet where it's a
whole other even larger problem there's
a belief that the days of finding a mass
audience for news or shrinking the the
opportunity to get a truly mass audience
of shrinking and therefore
you need to pick your audience and
appeal to that audience basically run up
a flag that says listen this is what we
believe and if you believe what as we
believe then tune us in every night and
tune everybody else out and whether it's
Fox on the right or MSNBC on the left
this is a growing trend you may have
read in the newspapers recently that CNN
which has tried to carve out what it
calls a middle-of-the-road path is
suffering badly so it has to do with the
fractionalization of the audience and
this increasing tendency to say look
pick your audience pick like-minded
people and appeal to them and that's the
best way to survive I don't agree with
that but when you ask why is MSNBC doing
this and why is Fox doing what they're
doing
that's the reason sure okay
you painted a really great picture of
your young self bedridden being
emotionally moved by these radio
broadcasters I'm curious if your senior
counterpart sitting there today is moved
as emotionally by anybody working in
journalism in any form today and if so
who I'm pausing because to give you the
names of one or two would be to leave
out a lot of people let me just say that
widely believed it may not be but true
it is that most journalists of any
reasonable experience what he or she is
trying to do you judge how well I have
poorly to do it is to be an honest
broker of information and to be an
honest broker of information I do think
takes dedication and a certain amount of
passion and there are a lot of
journalists both names you might
recognize and names you might not
recognize who out there every day that's
what they're trying to do that's we're
trying to do people make their own
judgments about them
we'll say that is increasingly difficult
whether you work at a local station a
newspaper a radio station television
station or either Network because of
what I mentioned before the the craft of
journalism is in a period of contraction
I don't think it will last forever but a
period of contraction so the journalists
this is way too often goes on I spoke
before about not having we need a spine
transplant so often what happens the
journalist says why that looks like a
real story to me I'll give a
hypothetical example I think the mayor
is involved in getting rezoning part of
this section of town out here sort of a
classic investigative case the
journalist says I really want to look
into that yeah the part him says you
know what I'm not so sure that the
station owner doesn't have a piece of
this land himself and you know what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna get in the
middle move with the mass not taking any
chances not taking any risk and I'll
keep my eyes and ears open but pretty
much let it slide that's the you know
that's the danger and particularly in a
tough economic time and a time when the
the craft the profession is shrinking
it's pretty hard to say well I've got
the character I'm strong enough I'm
gonna run the risk in the abstract I can
preach it and we can say that's what
needed to be done but if you're young
journalists married one child car
payments house notes where am I getting
another job this becomes part of the
reality
thank you hello thank you so much for
your words they're very inspiring as a
young person oh yes thank you for
sharing your words er they're very it's
motivating to hear your positivity and
your strength my question for you is in
the series that you're going to be
producing is your intent to educate
people about what's going on and just
sort of show you know give a new
perspective or perspective that people
can relate to and also when you're being
corporated you know sort of I guess
actions that people can take to mitigate
global warming in their own lives first
of all thank you
secondly what we what we attempt to do
what we attempt to do with our program
on HDNet we we hope to inform and
illuminate whatever story on whatever
story were working on we probably not
stretch probably we don't do enough of
having laid out the facts we know the
facts that are in dispute demonstrating
what the problem is one of our frequent
failings is we don't at the end of the
program or somewhere in the program say
okay if you understand what it is we're
saying you understand the problem you
understand the story and you want to do
something about it
here are ways that you might do that or
here are places to go to further inform
yourself and if you want to align
yourself there is some reluctance to be
perfectly candid with you what you
always try to be but we bare candid with
you there's some reluctance on my part
to do that and this is shared by a lot
of journalists because in my role as a
journalist I don't want to become an
advocate and you can say well by the
very fact you're doing this story you're
an event and it's listen that's not my
my goal is not to convince you to take
some action my goal is to lay out as an
honest broker of information what the
situation is you make up your mind
and again straightforwardly say - I lean
a bit - if we lay it out there then it's
up to you to find a way to act upon it
but I'm increasingly in the minority of
that having said to you we discuss on
the program from time to time not just
on environmental stories well you've
seen this and if you want to take action
here are places you might go we do it
sometimes but not very often for the
reason I just said I think this
gentleman here is an impatient thank you
thank you very very much it's a great
honor to have you here speaking to us
I'm really moved by it I'm and I want to
ask a question that follows on some of
sort of some of the themes you've sort
of come back to again and again and some
things have been troubling me for a
while which I'm sorry so that was all
preliminary so let me get to my question
so you didn't miss anything you've been
taught you talked about the role of a
journalist as a reporter as an honest
broker of information and in the context
of climate change when that when that
question was asked you talked about how
presenting the different sides and you
know six sides if there are and I feel
like often this is what we see in the
news is journalists saying okay being an
honest breaker means there's two sides
of an issue I'm gonna prove that one
side I'm gonna find someone I'm going to
present the other side but and that's
all well and good because there are some
things where there's no condition but I
feel like increasingly so there are
issues where people are just lying where
things are simply not true and it seems
to me that the term the journalism has
an ethical obligation to say when
something is not true to speak that it
is false and maybe even not have an
advocate for a position that is just not
true and I recognize that's extremely
difficult when you have things that
aren't true being championed by one of
the two major political parties often
and it seems to me that this is really
um and I and I recognized that people on
both sides of require often say things
that aren't true so I'm not trying to
say that only Republicans life but it
seems to me that it's really dangerous
for our democracy right now I feel like
we're increasingly living in an era
where we don't share a common set of
facts a common set of beliefs about
anything and so when the news story just
says here's one side here's the other
side people read it each take their own
side and they don't actually learn
anything and the conversation is
understand and it's first of all it's a
very insightful question and a very
important question and one that we
journalists discuss among ourselves
quite often but let me be clear about
something
having said before that sometimes the
two sides of stories sometimes at four
six or eight sides of the story but
sometimes the story is the story the
facts carry the story and there's an
inescapable conclusion that's number one
I don't consider that advocacy if you
lay out the facts you lay them out as
straight as you can and you give people
opposing points of view time to make
their points and I've never believed and
if if you give three minutes to one
point of view you have to give another
three minutes to the other point of view
I've never believed then that's part of
what journalism is about that
so in same thing the newspaper just
because you give eight inches on the
front page today to candidate a who has
said something propose a new policy or
said retracted something you said
candidate B has given his standard
speech for the 18th time he doesn't
deserve front-page news you follow what
I mean
so let's be clear that having said when
there are two sides you have an
obligation to give the two sides if
there's six or eight sides you have an
obligation do that here's what you're
trying to do what what what are you as a
journalist attempting to do what am i as
a journalist I'm attempting to get the
people in the audience as close to the
truth
as a humanly possible now if you happen
to be an aspiring journalist I caution
you that this can be risky which is to
say if someone is clearly speaking an
untruth and you listen to it and as the
interviewer I think you have an
obligation to say excuse me sir this is
what the record says now with no attempt
to be self-serving when you put up the
clip of President Nixon at that news
conference this happens high and low at
that point the stakes were high
the pressure was high but this happens
with journalists all the time and what
happened there this was only a short
clip he saved the president mr.
president you say the following things
the special prosecutor says and has
presented evidence and eyewitness an ear
witness testimony how do you reconcile
these two things and would call the hand
or if this happens with journalists all
the time at City Hall state legislature
of covering environmental stories I
quite agree and let there be no
misunderstanding
that as a journalist you have an
obligation when somebody speaks an
untruth to say it's an untruth there is
particularly in today's environment what
I've described before there's an
undertow that says well just go and
don't make waves but I don't consider
that to be responsible journalism but
for a journalist particularly beginning
journalists I don't mean to be
patronizing about this these are real
time problems that you don't want your
station manager your editor at the paper
or whoever's running your internet
operation to say well you know what you
went out and you only got one side of
the story it takes a lot of guts to say
well yes sir I did but let me tell you
on this story there is only one side of
this story or if he says you've got two
sides and they're four sides you say yes
but two of those four sides you're
pointing out don't have any credibility
see what I mean but we talked before
about doing quality journalism of
integrity a lot of that gets down to the
character of the journalist and make no
mistake
then when you attempt to speak truth to
power
we should become kind of a hack night
phrase but which I'm sorry for when you
try to speak truth to power if you say
mr. mayor what you've just said is not
true and I'm here to lay out to you why
it isn't true it will cost you something
you will pay a price of that whether
it's the mayor the city councilman a
spokesman for the opposition or a
president when you do that you have to
pick your places and the people fairly
carefully and when you do it make no
mistake you will pay a price for it yes
ma'am um I have a question regarding the
pervasiveness of corruption of the state
in the national level and how how then
to not underestimate the power of the
press how is it that we're supposed to
deal with this pervasive corruption
everyone's worried for their own neck
how do we how as a journalist can we
lose our jobs overcome this pervasive
fear it's got a stranglehold well the
straight answer is I don't know I
struggle with that myself
but I make clear that you know this is
the United States of America and people
have power that I think we as
journalists can do what I've tried to do
a small bit here tonight to enlighten
people not need patronizing waiver to
say listen I've spent a lifetime in
journalism let me tell you this is
what's happening these are the pressures
that you may not see huge corporations
in bed with huge government each serving
the other's needs and affecting what you
see in here I think most people have
some at least vague sense that that's
happening but it needs speaking out
people need to be informed about it and
I have confidence having said to you
before I'm an optimist by experience in
nature that once the public understands
this clearly obviously the problem is
with our everything from state
legislators to
the Congress to indeed whomever is
occupying the planets in a given time
you know I'm here from my viewpoint this
has to stop
I'm not Eddie I'm not any corporation
certainly not any capitalist that none
of that it's just I know journalism I
know what's happening with journalism
and if we don't get a handle on it then
my concern and I don't think there's an
overstatement that we can reach a point
where we're susceptible to the worst
kinds of outright propaganda spin is one
thing message management is another
thing but we all know what the end
result is when power decides to deal in
straight-out propaganda and there is
some risk of that if we continue going
the path now and answer your question of
what to do about it make noise when you
know tell people and encourage people to
say to a congressman listen I recognize
that you take campaign contributions
from big banks I recognize you take it
from big shipping interest in big oil
and I recognize you have to make some
compromises but there's some things that
shouldn't be compromised and this is one
of them and if your congressman hears
that from enough people he will begin to
adjust at least a little point that the
gentleman in the front row raised and he
was pointing out the difference between
being a reporter and an honest broker
let's take the example of reporters or
honest brokers journalism dealing with
science issues such as climate change
and I will argue that up until about two
years ago the New York Times was unable
to to cover the issue of the science of
climate change without putting in at
least a few paragraphs of the viewpoints
of the skeptics without pointing out the
3,000 scientists on one side differ with
10 skeptics but we're going to give a
few paragraphs to the skeptics or
without doing a separate story who are
the skeptics and who's paying them to
make the pronouncements they're paying
and it's particularly in the area
of science and climate change is an
example where journalism has led us down
by saying they have to report both sides
as if science is an opinion matter like
politics as opposed to fact-based I
would argue science is actually
fact-based and I don't think journalism
covers it well well I take your point I
respect your point hope you respect that
I respectfully disagree on several
several points I'm not a scientist but
science is in many ways constantly
evolving and as a journalist I'm going
to be open-minded it may upset you you
may not agree with it I will be
open-minded even if they're 500
scientists on one side and 10 people on
another my journalist experience is I'm
gonna listen to 10 people now that's a
different thing of saying I'm gonna put
them in my story in the newspaper or put
them on my Airways I do agree that
there's far too much yielding to
pressure not just the kind of big power
pressure we discussed before but the
pressure of I don't want to be
criticized or we don't want to be
criticized at the Times Washington Post
or what-have-you and this is the real
world of journalism that the very small
or perhaps tiny minority of voices
saying the facts aren't the facts the
truth are not the truth if they make an
up noise it's the editor or the right of
the story said you know what I'm not
tired of hearing this I'm tuck it into
the story I don't agree with doing that
I do agree that reporting on science in
general we focused here is what I think
we should in this environment on global
warming and climate change but the whole
area of sciences number one most
journalists including myself are
ill-equipped to report on science
specialization in science of people who
know science understand science and
therefore can be honest brokers of
information about science and
having said it's bad for reporters that
have been worse for editors about
knowing science and being able to report
science but I wanted you know stick
stick to your question that some of the
things that are presented as scientific
fact 50 years ago turned out not to be a
fang in Galileo's time it astronomy the
Astronomy at the time was considered to
be a fact
Galileo put the facts on the head so as
a journalist well it may make you
uncomfortable you may disagree with it
I'm always going to be open-minded for
the possibility that something in
science could change but we're pretty
far from them I think the the vertebra
of what should be talking about here
which is there's not enough science
reporting in general not just on climate
change but about science in general is
not enough reporting it particularly not
enough knowledgeable reporting not
nearly enough space air time given to it
and there is and this I do agree with
you there is to greater tendency to say
listen 5,000 scientists or 5,000 medical
doctors say this is the situation and
the same or equal anywhere near equal
weight given to 10 or 15 who say that is
not the case I don't think is good
journalism with that I agree
let's and we'll pick it thanks John hi
good evening mr. Wrather thank you for
your comments um one of the things that
she said earlier was that there's no
such thing anymore as a mass audience or
that the the probability of there being
a mass audience is declining but I think
one of the the major difficulties facing
the environmental movement is that the
people who are receiving the most amount
of information are the people who
already feel strongly about the issue
such as the people who are here in this
room how do you reach out to the people
who are skeptical about about for
instance climate change or the
importance of taking care of the
environment people who might be
skeptical about about what's going on I
thought that was the case you just
forgive me I wasn't sure they understood
the question well having said before
there are few things as powerful as the
facts and again this is a case sometimes
you have to be determined and persistent
skeptics by the definition if they
consider themselves a skeptical question
or a deep-rooted
skeptic on an issue such as climate
change you may not be able to change
their mind or they believe you may not
you may be able to do it only on the
periphery and you have to accept that
going in but my belief and I think the
record in history demonstrated if you
have the facts and you have evidence
that's short of factual but is very
strong evidence then it will eventually
carry the day and trying to look on the
bright side of things if with all the
problems particularly those over the
last few months on climate change and
trying to get people to understand about
climate change if you compare where we
were 15 years ago much less 25 or 30
years ago we've come a long way in
raising people's awareness of at least
and this is cautions but at least the
possibility of climate change there was
a time not too long ago if you talk
about climate change somebody was
thinking you were smoking something very
expensive or that you were a fringe
character now it at least is part of the
national debate certainly over the last
what year few months those who don't
believe in climate change for whatever
reason and I think most of them do
honestly have honest doubts but some are
in it for their own personal financial
and/or political gain but you know the
the the the inevitable counter-attack on
the consensus that was being built about
climate change as evidence itself over
the coming months but in the end the the
facts and let me put this in quotation
from the scientific facts which is we
accept the science of this day and this
is the overwhelming opinion of people
who know the subject can have spent
their lives in the end my own personal
opinion is it will carry the day it may
take a long while because again make no
mistake they are powerful interests very
powerful interests who would rather not
have we as a nation we as a society for
that matter engaged in this debate about
climate change but here's where my
optimism comes back that sooner or later
a consensus will emerge around climate
change but another thing to keep in mind
and since this is the last question you
say that I think we we Americans
sometimes we know it we're aware of it
we tend to forget this is a big
continental country big to ocean country
of 300 million people instill a new
thing in history
in that we are dedicated at both the
idea and the ideal that a nation as
large as this one geographically and and
in terms of population that is
multiracial multi-religious multi-ethnic
can hold itself United and move forward
by making intelligent decisions on
everything from foreign policy to
science policy this is to plead to
understand who we are what we are and
why it's sometimes difficult to reach a
national consensus or to coalesce around
national policy and I just it's a gentle
voice to say keep in mind that that's
what's happening with the movement
climate change movement of let's
recognize it and move forward and those
who are genuine skeptics and those who
are what I would call professional
skeptics listen you've been a great
audience I thank you very much I thank
Roger